we get started so I'm Leslie John and
are we ready to start I'm Lesley John
and I'm from Harvard Business School and
I'll be talking today about how to
change people's behaviors for the better
first I want to acknowledge my wonderful
collaborators on the projects I'll be
presenting today
George Lowenstein from Carnegie Mellon
Kevin Volt from Penn and also Mike
Norton from HBS so the way the approach
that I'm going to talk about today is to
get people to change their behaviors for
the better but doing so in a somewhat
counterintuitive way that is using
people's own irrationality to help them
help themselves and this approach is we
think particularly well suited to the
types of behaviors that people really
want to change but because of say
self-control issues they've been having
difficulty actually in stating that
change and so one domain where that is
really right for study here is health
behavior change so people want to
exercise more but come home after work
and repeatedly veg out in front of the
TV or they want to adhere to medication
regimens but fail to so I'll be talking
about this idea in the context of health
but I want to keep in mind sort of a big
picture that this approach can be
applied to many other domains and
perhaps I'd be curious to hear if
throughout this talk it you other ideas
come to mind within your own
organizations of context where this
approach could be used okay so without
further ado health behaviors
there are many disconcerting statistics
out there here's one on obesity so this
this rising prevalence and obesity not
just in the United States but beyond so
in 1985 there were no states with an
obesity rate of greater than 15%
flash-forward to 2005 and this is
flipped this is not a typo there are
none with fewer than 15% obesity rate
and obesity has a largely modifiable
behavior component
it and as do many negative health
behavior patterns in fact so one study
found that the purport when you when it
comes to premature deaths approximately
forty percent of these can be attributed
to behavioral patterns so modifiable
behaviors what's the common response to
these problems well from a public policy
perspective a common response is rooted
deeply in standard economic theory and
it assumes a variety of things for one
that people know what's best for
themselves which is often true
the second is I think more tenuous that
people are able to act on that
understanding and because of these
assumptions the general thrust of this
approach is to provide is to focus on
information provision as the main tool
so to inform people about the dangers of
smoking but oftentimes the problem isn't
information it's often a lack of self
control people engage in negative
behaviors knowing full well that they're
bad people are often overwhelmed by
information we can't process all the
information that's thrown at us all the
time moreover sometimes we use
information information can have
paradoxical effects sometimes it's used
in the for exactly exactly and end it to
be used at one example so there have
been several quasi experiments recently
on that have looked at the impact of
legislation that forces fast-food
restaurants to provide calorie labeling
and the idea being if you only knew how
many calories are in a Big Mac then you
wouldn't eat it and this these studies
that have looked at the actual impact of
labeling they have been mixed and on
occasion some have actually found
evidence of like a paradoxical effect
whereby this is a cute illustration of
this paradoxical effect that it could
induce sort of this calories per dollar
mindset if you post the number of
calories oh I want to get more bang for
my
in terms of like caloric density so it
could have the opposite consequence
enter behavioral economics so in
contrast to standard economics
behavioral economics that is the
integration of the application of
psychological insights into this
standard economic model behavioral
economics allows for mistakes so it
acknowledges that people's behavior can
be suboptimal
sometimes we behave in a way that does
not maximize our long-term well-being
and why is this the case this is because
we engage in a variety we are our errors
our decision making and judgments are
systematically biased to use dan Ariely
his popular book title we are
predictably irrational and it turns out
that these biases are really deeply
ingrained so it's actually quite
difficult to make someone not
overconfident so and so on the approach
we take I'm talking about today is to
instead of trying to D by L in a way
rebuy so use people's own decision
errors to help people help themselves
and so this is based loosely on a theory
and oldie but a goodie the theory of the
second best which posits that okay it's
best to not be biased at all but if
you're going to be biased in one way
sometimes it's you're better served by
not behaving optimally in every other
respect
in other words decision errors can
offset or counteract each other so let
me show you an example of some work that
George Loewenstein Kevan volp and I have
done and and others on how we can apply
this approach to weight loss so in a
moment I'll show you the specific biases
that we leverage so to speak but first
just to give some concreteness to this
idea what we did was we in different
interventions we've given people weight
loss goal say of losing 16 pounds in 16
weeks and then in one of these
interventions we
so people are randomly assigned to a
control condition or to different
financial incentive conditions that are
specifically tied to different decision
errors in the lottery condition again
I'll show you the nuts-and-bolts in a
moment of that but essentially people
can earn money so they're entered into a
lottery and if they if they attain their
weight-loss goals they can win money in
the deposit contract condition people
can put their own money at risk towards
losing weight so you put your money on
the line and if you don't lose weight
then you lose your money subjects are in
the incentive arm so we we tell people
so we have these weight loss goals and
we actually break it down into a daily
goal of what they need to weigh it's a
simple linear function of if it's 4
pounds a month 4 pounds divided by the
number of days in the month and so we
tell people this and every day they call
in their weight and they tell us what
their weight is and then we send them a
text message saying how their
self-reported weight stacked up to their
goal weight that day we also I should
say at the end of every month people
have to come into the lab so we see we
we we keep them in check so we they we
weigh them in on a study scale just to
make sure they're not lying and all
right so how do we play off of decision
errors so in this lottery incentive
condition one error decision error is
this tendency to weight probabilities in
a nonlinear fashion so for example if
you think of some event that changes
your likelihood of death from 0 percent
to 1 percent versus another event that
changes it from 50 percent to 51 percent
going from 0 chance to 1 percent that
one percent feels like it's much
stronger than if it's in the middle of
the scale so this encompasses these two
propensity x' over weighting of small
probabilities and also this
insensitivity to variations of
probability that occur in the middle of
the scale and so what does this imply
well for one it suggests that providing
probabilistic rewards for self
self-interested behavior in this case
weight loss will be effective now a lot
of this I call this is not just
behavioral economics so the psychology
literature in general has has suggested
this as well
specific to this intervention we in
terms of the the over weighting of small
probabilities our lottery has includes a
very small chance of winning a big prize
so the idea is you can get more bang for
your buck it feels like you're more
likely to win than you actually are so
you can get more bang for your buck if
you administer the incentive this way
relative to say an equal expected value
payment sure payment that's not a
lottery we also use regret so strictly
speaking I don't know that this is an
error but it can be a powerfully
motivating force regret so in
anticipation of regret people want to
avoid having regret and so this can
motivate people to change their behavior
so we use these things called regret
lotteries where we tell subjects what
they would have won if they had been
compliant it's kind of cruel but
effective so in the lottery incentive
condition how does this actually work at
the beginning of the study everyone gets
a two digit number say 27 and every day
of the study we draw a two digit number
now if the first digit matches say 25 in
this case or the second digit matches
you win ten dollars and now here's the
small probability you have a very small
chance
so both digits match if it's an exact
match you win $100 but only if you
called in and we're at or below your
weight that day so if it was a perfect
match and you called in your weight but
you were overweight you get this text
message saying you would have won $100
if you had only lost the weight now the
deposit contract condition for its part
also used a variety of different
decision errors this notion first of
present biased preferences so this is
another bias that encompasses two parts
one is the over weighting of amia
cost and benefits so we're impulsive but
at this in the same hand we are we tend
to take a more even-handed approach to
delayed costs and benefits so what does
this imply for one simply make rewards
for beneficial behavior frequent and
immediate tightly couple it to the
desirable behavior but also to take
advantage of this tendency to take an
even-handed approach to delayed costs
and benefits we want people to commit to
losing weight in prospect ahead of time
so people at the beginning of the month
say how much they put their money on the
line they commit to losing weight in the
future over optimism so we're overly
optimistic about our ability to exert
self-control especially when it comes to
health behaviors so this implies what we
do is we use these deposit contracts
people are overly optimistic about their
ability to lose weight and so this makes
them oh sure I can put I'll put money
down all no problem I I'll lose the
weight but then after after having by
virtue of having put the money down loss
aversion kicks in right this tendency
for losses to loom larger than gains and
so the deposits are non-refundable once
you put the money down it provides this
extra motivation to lose weight because
you don't wanna lose the money so the
way this works at the beginning of every
month of the study subjects think they
can put their money down towards losing
weight we have so in this particular
instance we matched we always match the
deposits we also included a three dollar
fixed payment because it was a bit of a
hedge we weren't sure if people would
actually put their money down in
practice and if so when you come in at
the end of the month if you're at or
below your weight-loss goal you get the
money back plus the match in the three
dollar day fixed payment now I mentioned
that that we told people we broke down
their goals but on a daily level and so
we actually gave people a little picture
of this to take home now one thing that
we were worried about maybe some of you
have thought of it already what if you
fall
tract from the beginning so weight
losing weight is really hard what if you
in the first month you don't lose any
weight then all of a sudden in the
second month to get your payouts you
have to lose eight pounds say which is
very demotivating we didn't want people
to Finch diet but at the same time and
we didn't want people to drop out but we
also wanted to be fair to the people who
were on track so we had this get out of
jail free card no he gave people whereby
we had a fresh start trajectory so
essentially in this case the redline so
say this person didn't lose any weight
in the first month instead of having to
make up for that in the next month we
spread that out across the rest of the
study we use so weight losses the DV we
also importantly used an
intention-to-treat approach so
especially in weight loss studies so if
you get people who drop out of the study
which is very common and you don't
properly account for this you can
overstate the effectiveness of the
intervention especially because you can
you often get more people dropping out
of the like incentive arms in this case
then in control and the reason people
drop out is very likely related
plausibly related to weight loss so it
could be that all the people that are
doing really badly drop out of the
incentives and if we didn't properly
account for that we'd be overstating it
so what we do is we impute anyone who
dropped out of the study we count them
as having not lost any weight we assume
that the intervention was ineffective
for them but I should say we got very
few people very few people dropped out
only about 10% which is quite low for
weight loss studies before I show you
weight loss these are the net paints so
the average payment per person this the
deposit contract is more because of this
$3.00 match which we've subsequently
replicated without the $3.00 match here
are the results so this is the weight
loss at the end of the study four months
so this is a four month study and the
dots with the error bars are the
the group means and then you can
actually see that all the other dots are
the individual data points and so here
we see that relative to control people
in these incentive conditions they lose
on average about 14 pounds so they lose
a lot more weight and interestingly
there's no statistically significant
difference between these two the deposit
contract in the lottery so this is great
but what happens when we so three months
after the end of the intervention we
followed up with people we asked them to
come back to the lab my follow up data
do not look nearly as beautiful as
Kate's so this is what happens after the
incentives have been removed so there's
substantial weight regain now the people
in the incentive conditions they still
they weigh less than they did at the
start of the study whereas in the
control condition there wasn't of
difference in the four months and
there's still not a difference from
baseline a month seven but you can see
that clearly the difference shrinks so
one of the things that we were curious
about we wondered whether when you
remove the incentives once the program
has ended we sort of set people off free
and we wondered whether we might be able
to help people maintain the weight loss
if we vary the way we frame this period
to people so it could be that
maintenance maintaining weight loss
causes people to sort of once you finish
the weight loss component you may sort
of let your guard down oh it's easy I
can maintain this so in the next study
we varied whether we just what we called
a maintenance period whether we called
it a continuation of a weight loss study
or a different distinct phase so in
another study this is a much longer
study so the intervention was eight
months and people received six months
worth of financial incentives if they
lost weight and then the final two
months they received the incentives
simply for maintaining the weight and we
varied what we called this we simply
what the framing was and this is we
removed this fixed payment we got rid of
the lottery for this one
so three conditions the control and then
these two deposit contract conditions
that only differ in the framing and so
we wondered whether if it's all called
the whole thing is a weight-loss program
you may take the whole thing much more
seriously than if the last two months
are maintenance well it turns out that
framing did wasn't a factor it was
probably a pretty subtle thing to be
looking for but we replicate this effect
of the deposit contracts they foster
weight loss relative to control and then
similar to the first study we followed
up with people after we had the program
it ended and what happens again people
regain the weight so just try to take
stock at the weight loss finding so far
on the one hand so these really point to
the promise and the perils of what we've
been trying to do so far one is so yes
they are very effective those approaches
effective in inducing weight loss and
it's also pretty engaging for people so
people almost everyone put down was in
the deposit contract condition was
willing to make a deposit which was
encouraging and the dropout rate was
really low and people were really
engaged they called in their weights
which are all great things but the
really disheartening news is this weight
regain which to be fair is weight loss
is hard so it's common in other weight
loss programs but it made us really
think what how can we administer this
approach in a way that doesn't lend
itself to this weight regain one thing
we've we've been thinking about is maybe
if we if so we remove the incentives
cold-turkey
what if we wean people off maybe that
will help them to maintain the behavior
change we also though this in this study
it's very we incentivize just the
outcome as in the weight loss and we
don't really give people guidance on or
try to shape the behaviors that lead to
weight loss in the next project I'll
talk about we use a more
process-oriented behavior we're trying
to get people to sort of be more fit be
more active
as opposed to directly incentivizing
weight loss and it also makes me so
paying people to lose weight or paying
people as as the reward is is very handy
because it's easy to administer it's a
sort of a universal reinforcer but it's
not without its problems so there's some
concern that you're sort of you may be
undermining people's intrinsic
motivation so to speak to do these
things if you impose this this external
reward and so it really made us think
about are there other ways that we can
sort of levers we can pull to shape
behavior so moving on to the next
portion of what I want to talk about is
this project called what we call walking
while working where we tried to get
sedentary call centers we sedentary
employees in call centers we wanted to
encourage them to use these things
called walk stations which the picture's
worth a thousand words I really want one
of these things and so we encouraged
people to use these for three hours a
week for six months and we simply varied
whether the feedback we the peer
feedback we gave people on usage so
people were everyone was every week you
got an email that simply told you about
your performance how often you how many
minutes you had spent on the walk
station in the preceding week and so
that's what happened in the solo
condition other people were randomly
assigned to a pair condition where you
get information on your own behavior
plus that of a randomly assigned
coworker and the group is your own plus
out of for other people so you use the
walk station X minutes you know
lastly used at X minutes and so on and
and so the email every week would
summarize this and we looked at walk
station usage we would have loved to
have we initially when we were
brainstorming with this project we
wanted to also look at customer service
surveys so you could think that if
you're on the walk station and like
looking at what does the that cost
two more think of you maybe you're
friendly or maybe at least a better
service unfortunately we weren't we
weren't able to get our hands on those
data but for the future so here's what
happened
now this is the average minutes spent on
the wok station every week for the six
month study and first of all there's a
clear time time trend so over time not
surprisingly usage decreases but solo
people that is people that only get
information on their own behavior they
are somewhat buffered from this decline
so the people in the pair and the group
do worse and so we we looked into the
data like what what do the data stella
data tell us on what's going on here so
first we looked at the group condition
this is where you get information on
your own usage and that of four other
randomly assigned people and we looked
first in the in the first month of the
study we identified for every group the
best performer so the person that uses
it the most and the worst performer the
person that uses it the least and we
plotted these averages so not
surprisingly so the best or the best and
the worst of the worst of these averages
but the question is what happens over
time and it turns out that these the
middling performers they get dragged
down to the worst performer so once they
see that someone else in their group is
not using the wok stations very much
then their own behavior sort of erodes
over time
the best performers are somewhat
buffered from that that decline now what
happens as a control analysis we took
the solo data these people don't get
information on other people's
performance but we created artificial
groups so postdoc we randomly assign we
drew randomly assigned people into
groups of five with the data and so we
created these synthetic groups out of
the solo data and similarly tracked over
time and if this does not happen when
you just look at the condition and you
create these artificial groups out of
people who did not in fact get
information on their P
this dragging being dragged down to the
worst performer in the group does not
occur so it's not it doesn't it seems to
be there's something about getting
information on other people's behavior
bad behavior that causes you in this
case to go down what happened and this
is a the parallel analysis for the
pair's so the real pairs are on top of
course we only have the the better
performer in the pair and the worst
performer and it's that the better
performer goes down to the worst not but
the worst is brought up by the best and
this doesn't happen in the synthetic
pairs so these these results are are
very intriguing to me and they're
actually consistent with some previous
research showing for one there's some
work on volunteering where in this study
people came to the lab and they had they
did a task during the time that they had
committed to be in the lab say an hour
and then the real study began at the end
of this hour where people could
volunteer their time and stay on for
another task so they could stay as long
as they wanted and what the researchers
were interested in was how long what are
the stopping patterns and what they
found was that as soon as someone
stopped volunteering others followed
suit which is similar to our results in
the sense that as soon as someone else
sort of shirk so to speak or doesn't use
this walk station very much then you
also stop using it as much it's also
consistent with some work that has
documented this sort of contagion
property of obesity that it seems to
spread so to speak through social
networks and a really cool study US
Airforce studies showing that people
that are randomly assigned to squadrons
made up of peers who were less fit in
high school that predicts your failing
of the fit the academies fitness
requirements so being randomly assigned
to people that are sort of
underachievers fitness wise chronically
causes you to has an egg
impact on your own behavior so in some
ways like the weight loss studies that I
opened with this raises more questions
than it does answers so this is an
example of when information can have a
negative impact on behavior and what we
also want to know is how can peer
information get people to do the right
thing and one thing that that could be
in the context of this study that could
be helpful
perhaps that there's a case to be made
for when less information is more in the
sense that what if we plucked the most
in the group if we only gave people the
information on the best performer every
week in their group maybe that would
mitigate the negative effect of seeing
everybody
so in conclusion I've talked about this
approach of using people's decision
errors biases or rationality to help
them help themselves and I've talked
about first the using financial
incentives and then also looking at
newer ways using social feedback how
that what is the effect of social
feedback on people's behavior to
underscore what types of behaviors does
this approach work well for or what is
it suited for that is the types of
things that people want to change but
they've really been having difficulty
accomplishing and sort of the beauty of
this point I think is that we're not
strong-arming people into doing things
that we think they should do these are
things that people want to change
they're willing to impose constraints on
the on their own behavior they sort of
opt in to so I'm as behavioral economics
is sort of vogue and I see more and more
I see companies doing things that are
clearly inspired by behavioral economics
popping up and so the the spirit of
changing people's behavior using this
approach is there but oftentimes I'll
see examples and they're just not quite
there
so the devil's often in the details and
how these things are implemented as an
example so my health insurance program
they have a fitness benefit where if you
use a gym if you're a gym member for
four months in the previous year then
you're eligible for a hundred and fifty
dollar benefit so the spirit of it is
great but the implementation could be
improved shall I say so what are some
flaws so this isn't totally behaviorally
informed implementation right so it
rewards once a year well we we know that
feedback is more rewards are more
beneficial when they're tightly coupled
to the behavior in addition it's a
really labor-intensive claim process so
you have to keep your receipt from at
least four months ago when you signed up
probably longer and then you have to we
have to remember to do this and then you
have to fill in a form that has quite a
bit of information you have to fill out
and then you have to mail it in so this
is totally incompatible with people's
you know the great inertia that people
face in trying to do these things and
and I would I would argue that you could
actually pay people a lot less the
benefit could be a lot less if it was
implemented in a different way and as I
noted at the beginning so health
behavior change is just one area that
this approach can be beneficial for but
some other promising domains
climate change so this is a doozy and I
you know I don't think that behavioral
economics can solve climate change
there's definitely something to be said
for the sort of standard economic
approach if you if you if gas is
expensive enough then people will change
their behavior but as I hope that I've
shown the way that you implement this
can have a big difference and if you use
insights from from what we know about
people's decision errors one tidbit here
on public transportation used as an
example you could think of so our
lottery incentive scheme you could think
of something similar with public
transportation like there's a lottery
every day
the lottery and if you if you have
swiped your metro pass on the subway
then you're eligible to win so there's
tons of there are lots of decision
errors and biases out there just waiting
to be exploited for good um saving so
Frank at the beginning of today referred
to this program by Thaler and Bernard C
it's called saving more tomorrow that
really capitalizes on these notorious
resolutions people make to save more
tomorrow but then when tomorrow comes
they never save so in this program they
get people to commit to saving money in
the future and that's a lot easier to do
than to commit to saving money now but
then when the future rolls along people
have sort of already locked themselves
in and their inertia takes over and they
don't opt out of that commitment they
made and this has huge effects on
getting people to say to save more money
charitable giving so you could think of
how some of the things I've talked about
today could be applied to either like a
call center scenario they work on the
requestor side or on the donor side and
there are likely to be many others I
think with that I will say thank you and
I'd love to hear thoughts you have on
this or questions so let's open it up
they look at suppressing the section of
the pie charter the information you gave
about genetic predisposition because it
seems to me that that's a big reason
people give both negatively and
positively about weight loss that my
genetics are my destiny and so I'm
protected whether or not I'm overweight
or I'm gonna die of a heart attack
whether or not I've overweigh because
they point to that section of the pie
chart saying your genetic predisposition
to heart disease is a significant factor
so people are you suggesting that people
sort of use that to like rationalize or
well it's hopeless because I'm I can't
change my behavior because I'm
genetically predisposed well-protected
so it doesn't really matter to feel a
certain right people right yeah that's
an interesting idea so are you so you're
saying that you you might be able to
play around with the extent to which so
if you tell people that like you could
sort of a preventative measure to people
would be to highlight your behavior you
know you can't rest on your laurels and
your genetic predisposition if it's in
fact to be thinner and you could also to
people that may be overweight you can
say no you can really 40 percent of you
know you can change yeah that's a really
interesting idea and more broadly the
way you can present information in a way
that really helps people to change
behavior and I think to come back to
Kate's talk that's another example of
you know the way the message matters and
the match of the message yeah
so for example weight loss if you offer
people a professional picture of
themselves at the 18 pounds later
whatever yeah new pair of pants or
something that would you know suggest
that maybe the weight loss yeah that's a
really great idea so as I mentioned like
the paying people is sort of it's an
easy way to incentivize I would love to
try more sort of hedonic rewards or more
you could think they the reward in and
of itself could be used to supercharge
behavior so like what if the rewards
were like gift certificates to healthy
stores or you could only buy fruit and
vegetables with this if that if that's
the reward so you could there's lots
more that we could do I think to to
change sort of use the rewards that are
in a in a more reinforcing way I guess
yeah is there juice to support you talk
it seems like the communicability
bad
yeah that's a that's a good question I
mean in the the behaviors that I've been
looking at sort of the easier thing to
do I would argue is to not exercise the
easier thing to do is to not eat healthy
in many ways especially given that like
the availability of junk food so for the
types of behaviors we're sort of the
dominant response is to be unhealthy I
think that peers can have exert like
this negative influence but it would be
interesting to see when you can flip
that and I and I'm not off the top of my
head I I don't know how to do that yes
for charitable giving I think you're
saying for saving commitment that
somehow I can't get out of my soup next
year yeah so I think that would be very
effective and in fact charitable
organizations often I mean this is just
anecdotally what I see is they're trying
to push their like small amount but
recurring stream of payments then one
big single gift and I think part of that
is based on this idea that you know it's
like it's a habit it's a status quo but
I think that if you you have to be sort
of delicate and how you implement this
because if you have to sign a legal
document that you're going to do this
then people are just gonna it could
foster reactance and people so the nice
thing for example to save more tomorrow
program you can change your savings
rates at any time but you don't because
of default so people still have to have
the freedom to change but yeah I think
does that get at your question
but just I mean you can explain to a
donor that that the organization needs
to rely on their promise
yeah make sense
feel like I'm ignoring the side of the
room yes Salus oh thank you um so in the
I'm the walk station then you had hi
walkers and meeting markers on the
walkers and it looked like the hi
walkers were gonna walk a lot anyway and
the people who didn't walk very much
we're lazy regardless of what happened
it was the people in the middle who are
kind of vulnerable depending on what
kind of network they were attached to
whether or not they had the address
information about their co-workers who
weren't walking very much is there a way
of predicting ahead of time who's
vulnerable to that so yeah I mean
certainly you can look at I haven't done
this but you could look at we have you
could look at sort of health assessments
in this company and see what predicts
you could certainly do that one of the
interesting things with this sinking
down to the lowest performer is that so
there was heterogeneity in the groups
like some groups are better than other
groups
so even when you had like so some of the
people that are best in each group
they're not actually stars in the grand
scheme of things they're just the best
person in that group so it's like a very
micro phenomenon that we see occurring
unfolding over time yes their
variability at some point during the
exercise one person taken
and somebody else or was it like static
one person got out to an early lead and
then uh it was so in general it was yeah
the front-runner the the it stayed over
time and so the if you look at like
different different if you
operationalize best performer in
different ways so if you look at who's
the best in the first week or like it's
it's it's the same pattern
yeah first of all days up to someone can
come so what would the average income of
the participants a so it was we ran
those studies in
population I think the median household
income was thirty thousand and so yeah
one might wonder sort of the like
diminishing marginal utility of wealth
whether this would be what is the
effectiveness of this type of
intervention in a more affluent sub
population because then people who are
resource constrained and wanna make that
change
see yeah yeah possibly yes Katherine and
particularly on the groups whether my
intuition would be if people know each
other and a group that that would have
influence versus those who would be
likely put together
so if you had a situation where you are
instead of it being exercised you're
told you're you're told how much other
people are donating is that what you're
saying
pressuring you yeah so here we yes we
randomly assigned people because we
wanted to look at sort of the pure
impact of feedback but actually that
might be something you could manipulate
is whether people get to choose their
own groups or not if it's randomly
chosen there could be differences there
yeah okay
yes do you have any longitudinal data
pass the two data points and did you see
anyone actually so the trends seem to be
decreasing if you see anyone increase
their walking and why yes so these are
just averages certainly there's some
variation but there is not I mean
systematically no but that said I am
very interested in social feedback and I
think that new technologies can really
be harnessed to sort of leverage the
power of social networks and there's
lots of studies that I would love to run
using social network type apps and
actually I just had one other thought
and then I'll leave coming back to Devin
that I just remembered where you were
talking about how you could like
presenting someone with maybe it would
be motivating to show someone a picture
of them likes or a lighter self and last
year my brother showed me this app that
he had found where it's the opposite of
that on a cell phone where you take a
picture of yourself and then it makes
you fat and like my reaction was was
just so visceral and it would be cool to
test like
when and why is it more motivating to
have the fat picture or the ideal and
moreover you could think of something
where you implement something like that
in a social networking site like you get
people to say pre commit to if I don't
lose weight this picture is gonna be
posted versus so there's tons of stuff
you could do anyways thank you very much